[Música]
vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Marta Moya Marta Un saludo para usted
Hola Ángela muy buenos días los buenos
días también para ustedes Marta y vamos
a empezar con una exclusiva de la CNN en
la que se evidencia al parecer que el
presidente Donald Trump ex presidente
habría mentido cuando dijo que había
desclasificado todos los documentos
secretos que tenía en su poder una vez
salió de la Casa Blanca Incluso se habla
de un ataque a Irán cuéntenos usted Pues
sí Ángela la CNN pues ha obtenido o ha
dicho que la fiscalía general que está
investigando no las presuntas
irregularidades de tenencia de
documentos clasificados por parte del
expresidente Donald Trump han obtenido
esta grabación de audio que parte de una
reunión en el verano de 2021 en la que
el expresidente Donald Trump tendría en
su poder un documento clasificado de la
inteligencia del pentágono que habla
sobre un eventual ataque a la República
islámica de Irán nos remontamos a Julio
de 2021 una reunión en el club de golf
de Donald Trump en New Jersey en la que
tiene Pues un encuentro con varios de
sus asesores y se reúnen para
redactar o para ayudar a redactar las
memorias del ex asesor de Donald Trump
Marc metals en la grabación se escucha a
Trump moviendo unos papeles sin embargo
no se puede determinar si eran esos
documentos clasificados pero si se
destaca en esta grabación que Donald
Trump sabía Pues de lo controvertido Y
de lo peligroso que era tener esos
documentos en su poder después en el
libro de Mark Mouth que ya salió
publicado se dice textualmente recuerda
un informe de cuatro páginas escrito a
máquina por Mark Milly que contenía el
plan del propio general para atacar irán
desplegando a un gran número de tropas
algo que instó al presidente Trump a
hacer en más de una ocasión durante su
presidencia Mark mil y recordemos Pues
el jefe del Estado Mayor conjunto de
Estados Unidos nombrado por Donald Trump
en el año 2019 y que ha tenido una
tumultuosa relación con el expresidente
además en esta grabación de audio
también se ve a Donald Trump criticando
a Mark Milly todo ello porque días antes
de que se diera esta reunión él también
la publicación de New yorker había
publicado que Durante los últimos meses
de la presidencia de Donald Trump Marc
Milly había reunido a los suyos a su
gente para evitar que el presidente
llamara al ejército para pues actuar
cuando Donald Trump no reconoció las
elecciones de 2020 y después también
para evitar un presunto ataque contra la
república islámica que no estaría
liderando Marc Milly sino que estaría
liderando Donald Trump porque la
justicia ha determinado que Mark mil no
fue quien redactó ese documento del que
ha hablado Donald Trump en esta
grabación Por tanto se podría complicar
toda la situación para donal en medio de
las elecciones su equipo sigue diciendo
que todo esto es una persecución
política contra él pero sí Pues esta
grabación evidenciaría que Donald Trump
mintió cuando dijo que todos esos
documentos estaban desclasificados un
caso más contra Donald Trump un casos
más para la palestra pública y la verdad
Marta es que pues sí se podría complicar
la cosa pero también le podría favorecer
como ya hemos visto que ha sucedido en
el pasado con otros casos Pero bueno
vamos a seguir en ese país Porque además
soy de Washington post publica un
informe pero ahora hablando del
presidente actual Joe biden en el que
dice que el mandatario muestra un
creciente apetito por cruzar las líneas
rojas del presidente ruso Vladimir Putin
De qué trata este artículo Pues sí
Ángela Ese es el titular del artículo
del Washington Bosque destacamos hoy que
dice que a pesar de las continuas
advertencias de que armar Ucrania puede
desencadenar en una nueva guerra mundial
pues Joe biden está desafiando todos
estos límites impuestos por el
presidente Vladimir Putin
la estrategia que dice el Washington
post puede traer riesgos y también
recompensas a lo largo de estos meses
recordamos Estados Unidos ha ido
ampliando ese arsenal de armas con el
que ha ido nutriendo a Ucrania desde
lanzacohetes imars hasta el último deseo
o la última confirmación de enviar
aviones de guerra de Última Generación
f-16 este último anuncio Pues dice
Vladimir Putin que sobrepasó otra línea
roja y que podría desencadenar en un
conflicto directo entre Washington y
Moscú sin embargo funcionarios
estadounidenses dicen al Washington post
que hasta el momento Joe biden ha venido
desafiando estas amenazas principalmente
porque Rusia no ha cumplido también con
sus propias amenazas de castigar a
occidente por armar a Ucrania pero que a
la vez todo esto genera mucha
incertidumbre de si Vladimir Putin Pues
en algún momento va a actuar no
gestionar el riesgo de esta amenaza y
esta incertidumbre sigue siendo sigue
siendo el gran reto de la política
exterior de Joe biden esto dice el
Washington post además que hasta ahora
las consecuencias directas que ha tomado
Moscú contra Washington han sido tres
concretamente retirarse del tratado
sobre control de armas neostar segundo
encarcelar al periodista
ivanguerscovic sin más motivos por
presunto espionaje y tercero sentenciar
a la basquetbolista Britney grainer a 9
años de cárcel que recordemos después
Fue liberada en un canje de prisioneros
sin embargo no ha atacado militarmente
ni a Washington y a ninguno de sus
aliados por eso biden se está
permitiendo estas licencias dice este
artículo del Washington bosque tampoco
Cabe destacar que está creciente amenaza
pues al final se materialice sobre todo
después de los misteriosos ataques en
las regiones fronterizas con Ucrania y
también en los ataques al kremlin con
drones de principios y finales de mayo
citado por último un experto en defensa
dice este artículo del Washington bosque
existen ciertas líneas rojas pero debido
a que no sabemos con certeza cuáles son
es lo que genera ese riesgo No es que no
tenemos ni idea porque cada vez que un
nuevo anuncio de armamento pues
pareciera que se amplía ese Rango no
Marta pero en estas llevamos ya más de
un año y al parecer la movilidad al
menos directa no existe vamos a terminar
con una nota que creo que nos merecemos
de The Garden usted sabe la carga mental
que es para el periodista ver tantas
noticias como las que nos acaba de
contar y también para los televidentes
pero este medio destaca en otros temas
el gran éxito de la Banda Queen bohemian
rhapsody que no iba a llamarse así en un
principio Pues si Ángela onda todo
curioso que se ha revelado después de
que se conociera que el borrador
original de este gran éxito de Queen de
1975 va a ser subastado hasta ahora esto
un dato desconocido tanto por fanáticos
como por los biógrafos de la banda y de
fredo y Mercury los papeles originales
destacan dos datos curiosos el primero
es que originalmente la canción no se
iba a llamar bohemian rhapsido el
rhapsody sino que se iba a llamar
mongolian rapsody después fre Esa
primera palabra Y puso bohemian y el
segundo dato curioso es que los primeros
versos de la canción que dicen como mamá
acabo de matar a un hombre le puso una
pistola dispara el gatillo y ahora está
muerto tampoco iban a ser así sino que
iba a empezar la canción diciendo mamá
inició la Guerra tengo que irme esta
noche tengo que pararme y luchar este
borrador de 15 páginas está tasado en
1,2 millones de libras esterlinas y ya
pues nos ha dado este dato curioso que
revelamos hoy de que pues
rhapsody no se iba a llamar así
originalmente una pieza maravillosa a
usted le gusta a mí me encanta Pues
bueno entonces gracias por traernos ese
dato que nos alegra un poco la mañana y
nos da un poco de de tono emocionante
Muchísimas gracias Marta gracias Ángela
esta mañana